grazie a tutti buongiorno io sono
appunto guido caldarelli vengo dagli mt
in questa nuova istituzione fondata una
decina di anni fa che è una scuola di
dottorato e inizierò con una storia una
storia che vi voglio raccontare oggi
come immaginate dal titolo una storia
complessa
i protagonisti di questa storia sono
bambini telefoni cellulari e foche e
merluzzi se riuscirò a convincervi che
tutti questi protagonisti fanno parte
della stessa storia allora vi aveva
spiegato sufficientemente bene
l'argomento delle reti complesse
allora iniziamo con i primi protagonisti
che sono i bambini
questa è la mia classe delle medie
potete riconoscermi se sono un po
cambiato ma dovreste riuscire a trovarmi
in questa foto è una foto dei ruggenti
anni settanta vedete l'abbigliamento si
possono dire parecchie cose
anche oggi si fanno le foto all'interno
delle classi delle scuole si fanno le
foto anche per le squadre di calcio c'è
sempre una struttura che viene che viene
conservata in tutte queste queste foto
ed è il fatto che le persone più altri
ragazzi più alti stanno dietro quelli un
po più bassini davanti in questo caso
neanche tanto perché eravamo tutti più o
meno della stessa altezza in questa
classe è però questo non c'è niente di
strano se noi andiamo a misurare quello
che succede allora troviamo che
all'interno di una classe scolastica
come questa qui ci saranno dei bambini
misuriamo quanti sono alti un metro e
mezzo che più o meno l'altezza che ci si
aspetta per un bambino che entra in
prima media
la maggior parte avrà appunto questa
altezza di un metro e mezzo ci saranno
delle code ci saranno dei bambini che
sono un po più alti dei bambini che sono
un po più bassi ma un metro e quaranta
un metro e sessanta stiamo parlando di
differenze di decine di centimetri non
più di così
e questo è quello che succedeva io sono
il primo anzi il terzo nella prima fila
da sinistra però questa questa idea
appunto come abbiamo sentito nel primo
talk che ha aperto questa
mattina di linearità naturalmente non è
lineare questo distribuzione questa
distribuzione a campana naga ussia na
però questa questa idea che ci sia un
valore medio che rappresenta un po tutti
e che ci siano piccole deviazioni da
questo valore medio come la linearità è
abbastanza insita nella nostra mente
oramai siamo inclini a pensare che
questo succeda sempre e per validissimi
motivi questo succede davvero molto
spesso però quello che succede è che non
è sempre sempre vero
prendiamo un altro esempio questa è new
york e la borsa valori un giorno
qualunque
perché da sempre lì si comprano e
vendono azioni semmai applicassimo lo
stesso ragionamento la stessa linea di
pensiero potremmo cominciare a pensare
che qualcuno venderà o comprerà una
decina d'azione qualcuno 5 qualcuno 15
non è così le transazioni che avvengono
gli sono transazioni di poche decine di
azioni in un caso altri casi di migliaia
e migliaia di dollari e questo succede
perché come probabilmente già avete
immaginato già sapete la distribuzione
delle ricchezze il reddito che la gente
a non è distribuito secondo quella curva
che abbiamo visto prima e distribuito in
maniera molto diversa
ci sono tante persone che hanno un
reddito sufficiente per vivere
e poi ci sono altre persone e sono molto
poche che hanno tantissimi soldi come
mister bill gates alla fine di questa di
questa curva in realtà questo è solo
un'immagine così tanto per tanto per far
capire di cosa stiamo parlando se
dovessimo mettere davvero il signor
bellezza in questa distribuzione sarebbe
molto in fondo probabilmente fuori dal
teatro e allora questa legge è una legge
fra l'altro universale e stata scoperta
da un italiano da vilfredo pareto nel
1890 e rotti che come molti colleghi
italiani lavorare all'estero a losanna e
lui e scoperte appunto che la
distribuzione del reddito non obbedisce
a quello che uno si aspetta che ci sono
delle persone che guadagnano più o meno
un certo valore
poi ci sono delle code con qualcuno
guadagna un po di meno e altri solo un
po di più
no no le differenze sono molto profonde
e passiamo al secondo protagoniste
telefoni cellulari
questo succede molto spesso in realtà
specie nei sistemi tecnologici e se voi
considerate per esempio una rete di
chiamate in cui solo una piccola parte
di una rete di telefonia mobile quindi
pallino è un numero è una linea che
conosce due pallini o chiamata fra
questi due numeri vedete che cioè
qualitativamente la stessa cosa molti
telefoni fanno poche chiamate alcuni ne
fanno tantissime per esempio quello al
centro o quello un po più in basso a
destra
sappiamo anche chi è questo che fa molte
chiamate a quello di viaggio con in
treno di solito adesso abbiamo davanti e
non smette mai
e qui l'abbiamo finalmente acchiappato
visualizziamo vediamo che sta lì
il nostro telefono però adesso uno
smartphone anche un piccolo computer
magari andiamo su facebook magari
tweetiamo in questo momento magari voi
lo state facendo e se andiamo a vedere
una mappa di internet dove qui questa
volta i pallini sono degli autonomous
system sono degli insiemi di computer e
una linea fra due palline che non si
vedono da conto quante sona da quanto
sono piccole è un collegamento che li
unisce su cui viaggia per esempio
un'email o un pezzo di un'email
allora vediamo che anche in questo caso
ci sono dei nodi delle palline dei
vertici in cui ci sono tantissimi
collegamenti lì a destra o lì in alto
quasi quasi la metà a un terzo del
collegamento totale è dato da questi
piccoli nodi questi hub che in realtà
collegano poi tutto il sistema e questo
è una caratteristica non solo di
internet ma di tutti i servizi che sono
definiti su internet se voi guardate le
pagine web che sono dei documenti creati
o conservati all'interno di hard disk
dentro questi computer e anche per loro
troveremo una struttura di questo tipo
ci saranno pagine che hanno molti link
entranti molti che le puntano come
google e altre pagine che non ne hanno
per niente e questo non succede solo per
solo per il web
ma succede anche per tutti gli altri
sistemi questa è un sono delle piccole
mappe fatte nel mio intorno di facebook
di twitter in cui io sono al centro e ho
dei contatti ma dei miei vicini alcuni
ne hanno pochi e altri ne hanno
tantissime questo insomma succede sempre
succede sempre e succede non perché sia
una deriva del mondo moderno che ha
creato una tecnologia un po strana ma è
sempre successo e anche una
caratteristica se volete delle scienze
sociali
questa è una mappa una mappa che parla
delle famiglie fiorentine nel
rinascimento le famiglie sono i vertici
di questa mappa è una linea che unisce
due famiglie un matrimonio quindi un
modo per allearsi invece di combattersi
sempre allora che cosa si impara da
questa rete che ci sono delle famiglie
che hanno capito che essere molto
connesse un vantaggio che essere molto
centrali quindi di stare avere una
distanza che piccola rispetto a tutte le
altre può essere conveniente indovinate
chi sono sono i medici quindi queste
questa famiglia pur non conoscendo la
teoria delle reti in qualche modo
intuitivamente aveva capito che è più
conveniente essere in certe posizioni in
una struttura sociale piuttosto che in
altre o essere isolati come i pucci che
l'estremo opposto a quello dei medici
non è una cosa particolarmente buona per
la carriera e quindi questa cosa succede
sempre succede da molto tempo e le
differenze di cui parliamo sono
differenze davvero importanti se noi
andiamo a rivedere queste due curve che
descrivono questi due tipi di
comportamento quello della curva a
campana e quello invece dei redditi
delle amicizie dell'importanza sociale
vediamo che si parla di differenze reali
quando noi vediamo la distribuzione di
altezza e quelle dei bambini uno sarà
alto un metro e mezzo qualcuno me 360
qualcuno un metro e 40 ma nessuna alto 2
mm nessuno in alto 20 km
ma questi mostri non esistono per
fortuna ma quando noi parliamo dei
redditi quando noi parliamo delle
connessioni che ha un autonomo system
quando noi parliamo dei link che diceva
una pagina web allora è molto differente
allora ci sono dieci cento mille
diecimila volte di più
questo è quello che succede nelle code
ci sono delle persone che hanno
tantissimi contatti tantissimi amici
questo che cosa vuol dire che cosa ci fa
capire che cosa poi studiano le persone
ci fa capire che queste reti che si
chiamano in varianti di scala sono state
anche chiamate nella traduzione di un
libro di mark buchanan reti
aristocratiche queste reti sono più
fragili di quello che uno si aspetta se
un sito un super connettore quello che
ha
tanti contatti va giu crolla e questo
può far andar giù l'intero sistema o una
parte consistente di esso un mezzo un
terzo su questa rete una rete di questo
tipo chi sta al centro in qualche modo
avvantaggiato
e però può essere un problema se noi
pensiamo che tutti noi vediamo 45
persone al giorno possiamo immaginare un
modello di epidemiologia che ci dice
come funziona l'influenza come si
diffonde e arriviamo a certe conclusioni
queste conclusioni sono sbagliate perché
non è vero che ognuno di noi delle 45
persone al giorno se lavorate
all'aeroporto di quito jeff che io un
grandissimo ab
magari ne vedete 10.000 in un giorno
basta che voi siete malati per propagare
in tutto il mondo una pandemia basta una
persona sola su una rete di questo tipo
quindi c'è una fragilità intrinseca in
questi sistemi
questa fragilità alle volte si
moltiplica perché le reti possono essere
interconnesse quindi la fragilità di una
si moltiplica con la fragilità
dell'altra e così via
e questo succede particolarmente nei
sistemi economici e finanziari che la
cosa di cui io mi occupo agli mtv faccio
un piccolo esempio questo una mappa
vecchia una mappa fatta nel 2005 è una
rete di comproprietà chi possiede chi
alla borsa di milano
nel 93 quindi stiamo parlando di
parecchio tempo fa una ventina d'anni fa
amy possiamo fare molti discorsi ma è
semplice
voi la guardate e capite chi è che è più
importante in questo sistema e chi sono
gli hub sono mediobanca e generali
quindi subito sapete quali sono i nodi
fragili di questo sistema i nodi che se
falliscono fanno fallire anche le
società in cui partecipano per esempio
questo è solo un solo uno degli infiniti
o quasi infiniti lei e rossi sistemi in
cui potete immaginare di guardare il
mondo economico e finanziario
potete per esempio andare a vedere alla
rete dei prestiti fra le banche trovate
una struttura molto simile
la cosa che particolarmente
importante in questa rete di prestiti
fra banche che è una rete che è stata
creata per ovviare ad un'altra fragilità
il problema è quello della liquidità
se le persone stando a una banca sta per
fallire allora vanno di corsa a
prelevare dal proprio conto corrente i
soldi si mettono in fila e cercano di
portare a casa quanto più denaro
possibile per non essere coinvolti nel
fallimento della banca
naturalmente se tutti i correntisti si
mettono in fila cioè in un giorno
qualsiasi
la liquidità per tutti
questo è un esempio delle varie
possibili crisi di liquidità e poter una
banca complicati nel mercato vari altri
mercati però per ovviare a questo la
banca centrale europea per esempio una
delle tante misure è quella di
assicurare che nel denaro contante sia
depositato sempre presso la banca del
paese in cui queste banche operano nel
nostro caso della banca d'italia quindi
2 per cento del fatturato va depositato
ogni mese è una riserva liquida a cui le
banche possono attingere in caso di
necessità
però quello che succede che quando
arriva il giorno di depositare questi
soldi le banche magari non ce l'hanno le
hanno investiti e devono chiedere in
prestito e si origina un mercato un
mercato di prestiti fra le banche che
naturalmente anche altre altre funzioni
oltre a questo ma insomma in cui operano
per questa direttiva è la rete che si
forma e ancora una volta una rete
fragile ci sono alcune banche che sono
al centro che hanno la più parte dei
collegamenti e molte altre banche invece
fanno pochi e transazioni sono la
periferia
quindi se le banche centrali hanno un
problema e non possono intervenire in
questo mercato questa che dovrebbe
essere una rete di protezione non
protegge assolutamente niente quindi è
fragile essa stessa quindi una richiesta
di irrobustire il sistema ha creato una
nuova fragilità e queste cose succedono
continuamente i sistemi economici e
finanziari sono anche un po alla base
della crisi che stiamo vivendo in questo
periodo
e
l'ultimo protagonista alle foche i
merluzzi allora che cosa si può fare per
controllare queste reti complesse che
cosa si può fare per studiarle per
capirle vi faccio vi racconto l'ultimo
pezzo di questa storia che è un esempio
che viene da un fatto realmente successo
negli anni settanta in canada
questa figura che vedete sulla destra
molto complicata e piena di linea è una
rete una rete ecologica una rete
alimentare sono le i rapporti di
predazione kim han jackie nell'atlantico
in cui ci sono varie specie nel mare ci
sono i merluzzi che vengono pescati e
sono molto cari quindi vengono venduti
molto bene dei pescatori i predatori di
questi merluzzi le foche per esempio e
non ci sono gli uomini che sono accaniti
i predatori di questo pesce che viene
venduto in tutto il mondo negli anni 70
per vari motivi non ancora compresi fra
cui anche la pesca intensiva
il numero di questi e merluzzi e
cominciò a scendere maniera molto forte
mettendo a rischio la vita delle persone
che vivevano di pesca dei pescatori
il governo decise di correre ripani di
trovare un modo per cercare di
incrementare la popolazione
allora qual è la cosa semplice che uno
pensa avranno dei predatori oltre a noi
le foche
se noi uccidiamo questi predatori beh ci
saranno ancora più merluzzi quindi
abbiamo l'ordine di uccidere ha poi
anche in maniera abbastanza cruenta le
foche e ci sarà più pesce per noi non
necessariamente questo è vero sistema lo
vedete come complesso non è neanche
lineare la relazione che lega la
predazione alla popolazione delle specie
allora quello che è successo e che poi è
stato capito quello che successe insomma
si vede subito i merluzzi diminuirono
ancora di più dopo che le foche venderò
quasi sterminate perché questo perché le
foche erano predatrici anche dei
competitori dei merluzzi quindi questi
competitori che non erano buone da
mangiare nessuno pescava si trovarono
senza predatori e con i propri
competitori merluzzi
venivano invece pescati intensivamente
degli esseri umani e quindi occuparono
tutta la nicchia ecologica e quindi non
necessariamente fare un'azione che
sembra ragionevole razionale porta al
risultato atteso
questo vale per tutte le reti complesse
e quindi le conclusioni che noi possiamo
trarre da tutta questa storia sono che
il modo in cui siamo collegati incide in
quello che ci può capitare le persone
che sono più centrali sono più influenti
e rendono però il sistema anche più
fragile quindi essere molto collegati
alle volte può essere un bene alle volte
no non lo è per niente
nel caso dei sistemi finanziari noi
possiamo avere delle istituzioni che
sono collegate fra di loro ha un certo
livello di assicurarci che a questo
livello tutto vada bene però le stesse
istituzioni vivono anche in altri
livelli magari non regolamentati gli
falliscono e questa cosa si propaga
dappertutto
quindi qual è la cosa che dobbiamo
imparare dobbiamo imparare che se
vogliamo controllare i sistemi complessi
dobbiamo cominciare a guardare chi è il
più centrale cominciare a guardare
quante connessioni a e in questo modo
forse riusciremo a fare una fine
differente da quella dei merluzzi grazie
per la vostra attenzione